cette défaite à pékin elle a été très
riche d'enseignements pour moi ça a été
une énorme claque parce que clairement
j'allais à pékin pour essayer de gagner
et d'enchaîner ces trois 3 victoires
voilà une petite touche à la porte 3 en
demi finale effectivement on me sort de
la finale donc ça a été dur parce que ça
a été une grosse remise en question la
question aussi j'avais 30 ans à ce
moment là la question d'arrêter ma
carrière ou de continuer et je peux vous
dire que les quatre années qui ont suivi
la défaite de pékin ont été supers
riches parce que humainement il a fallu
se reconstruire il a fallu imaginer et
créer quelque part une nouvelle manière
de me préparer le 31 juillet 2012 donc
lorsque vous remporté sept médailles
historiques cette médaille d'or
historique à londres vous dites que vous
avez été en phase avec les éléments
c'est la fois magnifique et terrifiant
ce que ça veut dire que ça tient à rien
une victoire à ça tient à rien
franchement ça tient à rien même si je
peux vous dire que chaque dixième de
seconde de cette manche je lui ai encore
gravé en moi se souvient de chaque appui
chaque coup de pagaie chaque gîte dans
chaque vague mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
deux trois fois dans la dans la manche
où je prends des risques ça passe mais
je sais aussi que ça pourrait ne pas
passer parce qu'il ya deux trois fois où
je passe à moins de 2 cm d'une touche et
c'est ça qui est assez magique parce que
ça dure que 90 secondes ces quatre ans
de travail quotidien qui sont jugés sur
90 secondes d'effort donc c'est une
vraie prise de risque
[Musique]